je suis sur la terrasse du château de
saint germain en laye et c'est une des
vues les plus fabuleuses de
l'ile-de-france regarder un petit peu là
vous avez la venue des loges ou bout là
bas vous irez le camp des loges où
s'entraîne le paris saint germain et si
vous regardez bien vous pouvez voir
david beckham qui est en train de faire
son jogging
si on se tourne vers la droite on a le
pecq le vésinet enfin toutes les villes
qui sont là bas ici en bas naturellement
le domaine nationale de saint germain au
lait et puis si on va de l'autre côté du
côté de la cour venait voir et là donc
on est de l'autre côté et là regardez
vous avez une vue sur paris vous avez la
défense qui est là le mot valérien et on
voit même alors là c'est un peu couvert
aujourd'hui mais on la voit un petit peu
on voit même la tour eiffel donc c'est
quand même la vue la plus exceptionnelle
sans doute de l'île de france et puis en
dessous là en bas parce que ce château a
été occupée par les allemands pendant la
guerre bat ya encore un blockhaus qui
est qui est resté voilà je voulais vous
montrer ça parce que ça vaut quand même
le détour savons comme fait jeter un
oeil par dessus parce que on voit
finalement que ben paris saint germain
c'est quoi ces 15 km à vol d'oiseau sait
rien du tout
il est rebutant domaine et cela depuis
six mois on va parler de vos projets
peut dire qu'il y aurait quatre terme
aux faux qui le résumerait c'est le b
sénat c'est le développement historique
c'est le nôtre et puis un quatrième
thème exposition à la composent par le
mécénat c'est évidemment indispensable
aujourd'hui c'est indispensable dans un
espace contraint on dépend du ministère
de la culture et de la communication qui
a renouvelé sa confiance et avec on le
voit des activités tout à fait
importante une collection archéologique
de niveau international qui accueille de
nombreux chercheurs et près de cent
mille visiteurs par an dont de nombreux
scolaires donc on a une vraie mission
d'éducation artistique d'éducation à
l'archéologie en tant que discipline en
tant que pratique en dépit de cette
conscience on sait qu'il ya des
contraintes sur les financements publics
donc j'ai pris l'initiative au mois de
décembre de lancer un club des mécènes
qui associe bien sûr des entreprises qui
peuvent s'intéresser à ce site à l'ouest
de paris et méconnue sur bien des
aspects et des particuliers qui ont
l'amour de saint germain l'amour du
patrimoine et qui pour nous ce qu'on
appelle le mécénat populaire aujourd'hui
peuvent s'associer mais aussi pour
montrer que il ya une appropriation du
patrimoine par les citoyens que le don
minimum pour pouvoir séculier il est
vraiment minimal ce dont nous n'avons
pas fixé sur les données du r'n'b made
me on peut devenir mécène et nous nous
ferons des événements évidemment c'est
normal par rapport à des mécènes des
soutiens individuels des visites privées
et des visites prestige des événements
particuliers destinés à ce public et on
souhaite qu'ils soient nombreux et ce
dîner a eu un effet de lancement et
aujourd'hui on en parle à saint germain
dans le nord des yvelines de façon à ce
que plus généralement à l'ouest de paris
ce grand site de l'histoire européenne
de l'histoire nationale et cette
collection s'inscrivent dans le paysage
francilien plus qu'elle ne l'est en
rangs corses est aujourd'hui une
nécessité d'une très grande très grand
succès des musées mais une très grande
concurrence des grands établissements
parisiens et bien à louer ce bien sûr il
ya le lot il y à versailles à un caleçon
soleil
couvre beaucoup de les ténèbres qui
s'auto tour il faut sortir un peu de
cette logique là travailler comme nous
faisons d'ailleurs avec un billet couplé
avec versa mais montrer que dans les
yvelines évidemment il y a un patrimoine
monumental et paysager tout à fait
spectaculaires liées à l'histoire de la
très longue durée est ici des origines
de l'humaine deuxième deuxième tome
c'est le développement historique parce
que on a parlé de l'archéologie billets
aussi de l'histoire si bien sûr il ya
une histoire importante de l'état de la
culture pensons que molière lui donnent
leurs premiers balais avec le jeune roi
qui aiment danser un philippe beaussant
le dit c'est un roi danseurs le 14 et
c'est ici dans la salle de bal qui est
arrivé dans la salle d'archéologie
comparer ils commencent jeunes ceux là
par la danse et à danser le menu est
laid et les ballets de l'époque donc
c'est le public demande cela il entre
dans un musée mais bien sûr il ya une
histoire depuis le moyen âge la première
présence des rois à l'époque moderne
jusqu'au xxème siècle en 1919 la pète
saint germain où les alliés décident de
mettre fin à l' empire des as beau gars
l'autriche hongrie et cette petite
autriche réduite résiduelles le pauvre
chancelier autrichien passe par un
escalier de service tandis que lloyd
george wilson et les vainqueurs orlando
pour l'italie pas se parler ce pari
d'honneur et par des dons qu'il faut il
faut remettre cette histoire voilà
comment la centre enfin on venait à
musée national qu'on a on peut avoir des
partenariats avec de grands partenaires
le mobilier national le nouveau pour des
prêts le multimédia la 3d si on a un
projet éditorial important dans ce
domaine qui va nous accompagner pour
constituer et faire revivre le château
neuf en 3d voilà aussi quand même pour
un site saint germanois majeur ce qui
pourrait être une réponse est un moyen
de développement culturel pour la ville
patrimoniale mais aussi touristique et
économique c'est tout ce que nous avons
souhaité présentée au mécène et c'est un
axe majeur aux côtés de la valorisation
de notre collection archéologique qui
reste le pilier est génialement de
l'action au sein du musée alors
troisième terme c'est un nom c'est le
nôtre 400e anniversaire bien sûr en 2013
nous fêtons le 400e anniversaire du
grand jardinier du roi l'homme qui a
constitué et réalisé dessiner les
parterres de saint germain et qui
arrivaient encore n'y a pas de
versailles il n'y a pas le verger à
chantilly vaux-le-vicomte via le réseau
elia saint germain saint germain est il
bien sûr la grande terrasse qui est cet
effet optique visuel tout à fait
impressionnant sur près de deux
kilomètres de long jusqu'au château du
val cette grande terrasse qui donne
l'illusion de du caractère rectiligne
alors qu'elle ne l'est pas le nôtre
épousant les courbes du terrain épousant
le modelé de cette partie de la vallée
de la seine et nous allons en 2013 faire
par de nombreux événements un certain
nombre d'hommages à cette figure de
l'architecte du paysage et du jardinier
ainsi que de lecture sur les jardins
avec françois marthouret comme lecteur
un grand acteur un grand-angle de
théâtre également des événements dans le
domaine avec des visites particulières
une nouvelle signalétique en six langues
dans le domaine national comme celle que
nous avons réalisés dans la cour du
musée avec renvoi pour d'autres langues
vers le site internet de l'établissement
et donc pour montrer qu'il ya un public
international qui peut découvrir la
trace qui est celle de notre à saint
germain et puis nous l'espérons nous
sommes en train d'y travailler avec la
ville de saint germain un projet
d'exposition d'artistes internationaux
dans le domaine avec patrick n l'instant
quatre
vingts artistes contemporains donc la
balle à l'entrée du contemporain dans
l'histoire je crois qu'il ya un sens
aujourd'hui parce que on est enfant dans
une forêt proche de la ville
périurbaines et dans ses jardins
sans trahir la mission je crois que
l'esprit de la création aujourd'hui le
travail in situ de certains artistes je
pense par exemple à ceux qui travaillent
des matériaux originaux en italie l'arte
povera ou à nos grosses en allemagne
peut s'inscrire comme dimension
paysagère nouvelles et pour inviter vers
le patrimoine il ne s'agit pas de
heurter les consciences qu'il s'agit de
les inciter à redécouvrir le patrimoine
ça donne souvent un regard qui permet de
regarder les choses autrement exactement
donc voyez signalétique lecture avec un
grand nom du théâtre et puis une
exposition de 20 artistes à partir de la
fin du mois de juin et dont on espère
que ça sera un des clous un des moments
importants de la saison le nôtre qui va
couvrir également toute la france et
notamment l'île de france mais qu'est-ce
qui vous souhaiter beaucoup de courage
ce qu'il en faut à ce genre de projet
puisqu'on a des artistes venus nombreux
horizons internationaux on peut par
exemple citer jan fabre qui est un grand
nom il on exposera probablement dans un
espace de l'établissement et l'idée est
de montrer à travers ça et aussi
j'oubliais des colloques et la recherche
on fera un colloque sur les jardins à
saint germain c'est une ville très verte
mais il ya la redécouverte au site toute
cette dimension paysagère et horticole
est également un colloque dédié à
l'archéologie desjardins au l'oublient
souvent on creuse et on découvre des
habitats des sépultures il ya aussi
l'archéologie des jardins de ce qu'était
un le paysage à l'époque romaine et au
moyen âge notamment en pratique tous ces
événements on peut les retrouver
évidemment sur le site alors on va
bientôt les annoncé officiellement mais
voilà on vous fait une primeur et je
crois que c'est important pour nous de
montrer que l'ensemble finalement des
établissements du ministère de la
culture est le nôtre notamment bien suis
cette année cet anniversaire très
important le nôtre a façonné si j'ose
dire le regard l'architecturé le paysage
de manière très forte il a inventé le
jardin à la française et un français
merci infiniment énorme merci patrice